meantime another of the president's
picks to a key national security
position appears to be against the
president's decision to reverse course
on tough penalties against a major
Chinese telecom company chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has the latest on that tonight
from Capitol Hill the president's
nominee to track terrorists encounter
threats singled out Chinese made phones
as high-risk would you recommend anyone
in any sort of position that sensitive
whether in commerce or in government
during contracting uses ET phone the
recent u.s. ban on exports to the
Chinese phone maker lawmakers heard that
Beijing uses technology to infiltrate
networks and steal Americans personal
information China
utilizes its telecommunication companies
for purposes of espionage even if those
companies leadership may not be open to
it they don't really have a choice but
to be cooperative
senator Rubio we've been on the record
in the intelligence community and law
enforcement of that fact the president's
Monday tweet that he wanted to help save
ZTE as part of a larger trade deal with
China drew criticism from other
lawmakers does it make sense to overrule
the advice and judgment of the national
security community and to offer ZTE a
way to get back into business fast
how are you raising those facts with
with this White House we are garnering
the support of the entire intelligence
community and regulatory community and
as a matter of fact I think we've had
meetings as well as us yesterday at the
White House in a letter to the president
32 Senate Democrats said he should put
American jobs and national security
ahead of Chinese business interests he
should keep the ban on ZTE it was the
first time we showed China that we were
going to be tough and meant business and
no sooner than that happens the
president backs off that for American
jobs on Russian meddling in the midterm
elections I don't think anyone in my
profession or the intelligence community
will and underestimate the potential of
the Russian Federation Vladimir Putin
with intelligence services and their
capabilities most but more importantly
their intent and a new warning about
sophisticated doctored videos called
deep fakes the deep fake the idea of
being able to create an alternative
reality if you add to that the powers of
social media it's a perfect storm of
disinformation I think what we saw in
the last election cycle their intent is
there in Turkey ability
clearly they're filmmakers were also
told that a growing number of foreign
adversaries have the cyber capability to
remotely access traditional intelligence
targets and to infiltrate critical u.s.
infrastructure and to do it without
attribution Brett Catherine Herridge
live on the hill Catherine thank you